thank you all for coming in the next 50
minutes or so I'm gonna tell you all how
exactly to build a wildly successful
enterprise application using Google
cloud platform
I'm Greg Hutchins I'm a engineer
in the cloud organization at Google but
I don't actually work on Google cloud
platform instead my team and I have
spent the past few years building an
enterprise application exactly as if we
were an external external team using
just the publicly available features
services and everything off Google cloud
platform so if you're going to build a
wildly successful application first you
have to decide what to build cloud
platform is not going to really help you
here for us we actually almost stumbled
upon this is that we were trying to grow
our team we had to hire people and
everyone we talked to kind of had horror
stories about how that worked in their
past at other companies it was really
everyone it was that from the candidates
to the recruiters to the employees at
the interview to hiring managers and so
we said well let's build this little
prototype just to manage this process
and make it better we won't spend much
time on it it's not that interesting so
we built the prototype started using it
and the more we dug into that space we
realized oh this is kind of interesting
like hiring is something every company
has to do it's a critical business
process and so from that we said well
let's actually make this prototype our
product and we'd override it in so for
you
choose something please don't choose
hiring what did we build we called it
hire super descriptive and what does
hire do it manages the entire process of
finding new employees from sourcing to
job postings to scheduling interviews to
adding feedback to kind of basically
hiring the person and we integrate with
all of the kind of the tools in G suite
you already know and love like gmail
calendar sheets Drive dogs etc and
actually even now we're starting to add
some more kind of AI powered features
which I'll talk a bit a bit more later
and are we wildly successful I'm maybe
not the best person to judge this but
we've launched roughly a year ago and
since then at least according to some
industry press were the number one
growing app in the space and beyond just
customer growth we've got a wide breadth
of customers in different industries
from retail to like health to restaurant
to construction and I think it's a
little bit in tech as well beyond just
that also is our customers seem to like
us we run these little surveys in an app
which we called happiness tracking
surveys which are basically customers
give it a thumbs up or thumbs down and
we get mostly thumbs up so we've built a
wildly successful application how did it
cloud platform get us there so normally
when you're choosing what cloud to use
it's between Google and I think there's
two other big names that come up which I
can't quite remember right now but for
us we're actually team at Google and
Google already has like the best
internal cloud in the world for building
deploying and maintaining global scale
services I guess I'm not biased there
but so why don't we using the internal
cloud at Google there's there's a number
of reasons first off the internal cloud
is like notoriously difficult to use
people talk about if you have a new
employee comes on it's gonna take them
six months before they're useful beyond
that also people joke about that once
you've actually come up to speed if you
want to use anything all the other
services internally there are either
currently in beta or already deprecated
so if you're building something you're
first to choose between something that's
beta and buggy or something it's
desperate or something that's deprecated
and you're gonna have to switch to
something new in a little while anyways
cloud platform on the other hand is
stable documented public you can
actually hire people with experience
it's got a coherent user interface
coherent command-line tools all sorts of
things to recommend it none of those are
the real reason the real reason it's dog
food dog food okay people don't say that
but here at Google we talk a lot about
dog fooding and eating your own dog food
this is actually an industry term I
believe you can look up the Wikipedia
page but what this means is you
basically volunteer or force your
employees to use the software you're
building and as the name implies this
isn't always that pleasant of an
experience even here in San Francisco
where the dog foods free-range organic
best dose free but so what we did is for
hire is that we built higher we've been
using higher since basically day zero to
hire everyone and that means our first
set of users are people right down the
hall where they can go yell at you and
say this feature doesn't work there's a
bug there's I don't understand why you
did this and you could use that feedback
to make things better and I guess very
seldomly they'll tell you this feature
is awesome it doesn't happen much more
than this though is that our entire
product entire hire hire product is
we're building it as if we're external
so we're actually doing a dog food of
all of Google cloud platforms we're
building an application just like you
guys are building applications and then
we can provide hopefully trusted
coherent feedback to the cloud platform
team about what works what doesn't work
etc and this dog fooding process is
really really important and if you're
building an application that you're not
dog fooding
I think about building something else
yeah so eat your own dog food it's good
for you and now on to how we built the
dog food like what did we use in Google
Hall platform a little bit first about
like hire architecture we're actually
really pretty standard enterprise app
we're built on something I call the
Shawn stack I'm pretty sure no one else
in the world uses that it's basically
that mean stack which is [ __ ] Express
angularjs nodejs where we've swapped out
[ __ ] with cloud spanner you can see the
diagram here is pretty standard we have
web browser we're using angularjs
mixture of JavaScript and we're now
moving to typescript they're packaged up
everything there with web pack which we
love and we're talking to various nodejs
app server backends those back-end spend
all their time either writing stuff to
span or a cloud storage or making
basically API calls to like the public
Gmail Doc's calendars etc step up this
is a place like source control you have
to pick something here Google actually
has this amazing internal system we've
written papers on it it's called Piper
it does the whole source control code
review I can see their repository
management and test as well
unfortunately we're acting as if we're a
third party so we can't use any of that
instead we chose get
everyone's favorite source control
system I think I like about get is that
if you can figure out how to use git it
makes actually writing your application
seem easy in comparison you think I'm
joking but I'm not it's my favorite get
man page as far as like you know for our
repository management and code review
tool use something like Garrett I
believe that was spun out of Google many
years ago for a while I used to complain
how much worse than github it was I
actually kind of liked it now it's under
active development it's open source it's
rapidly getting better
and then beyond just like you know this
even though we're using different tools
we're still following the standard
Google quote code review policy is every
changed its code reviewed everything is
tests speaking of testing I said we have
a homegrown you know test infrastructure
totally don't do this
with spending takes lots of time and
when we were first starting out we
evaluated everything out there with
third parties and at that time cloud
platform was relatively new there was
nothing we really liked so we went off
and built our own now I think today I
think the was that the cloud build was
announced definitely look at that and I
believe all the third parties at this
point support cloud Google Cloud but for
us what we have we're actually pretty
happy in it anytime you appreciate code
review it gets tested and you get your
results back in 30 minutes or less we
run basically our entire test suite
which is right now I think one and a
half thousand tests or one half thousand
Suites 20,000 test cases and I'm really
touched this like don't tell anyone but
I often make code changes without ever
running them locally as if our tests
pass it's good and that's pretty much
works out and yeah again don't do this
use a third-party but if you do this you
there's lots of things here that cloud
platform has helped us is that all of
our defects for all of this are stored
in cloud storage so this is like the
test test run or logs the app server
logs the freghar kind of end-to-end
browser tests we actually record videos
of where we click and so if you have a
front-end test that's fail you just
click that video and watch watch what's
happening the other piece we lose a lot
here is we're using bigquery I'll
mention that a lot today we really love
bigquery and so all the test runs
results goes in there we can figure out
which tests are flaky automatically
rerun them and then also for scheduling
we want to run our longest test first
and so that's also a big worry the other
thing we like is we use preemptable VMs
to keep cost down and here's a quote
from basically the engineer that built
all of this and his quote was don't use
preemptable VMs and really what he meant
was that we had a system that was built
without preemptively Em's and when they
came out we said aw let's just switch to
those and retrofit again turned out to
be really hard is that the number of new
failure modes added this took us a long
time to get back to stability but
definitely if you're starting from the
beginning definitely use parental VMs
other thing is maybe a theme here is
definitely read the documentation the
exact quote from the docs our
preemptable instances are XS compute
engine capacity so their availability
varies with usage which doesn't mean
that if you're using only printable VMs
any point they may all go away that did
happen to us once it hasn't happened
recently but just something to keep in
mind luckily it's really easy it's a
single flag to switch back to regular
VMs o talk about testing how do you
actually deploy things I actually tried
to draw a picture of what our release
process look like and start looking like
one of those diagrams from a serial
killer movie where you've got pictures
and string and all that so instead I
just put that picture of the canary here
and so you could try to explain this
verbally but they said we do push code
daily to prod but we only release
features to our DaCosta our customers
monthly what this means is all feature
work is hidden behind essentially
runtime flags as we found that table in
our database that lists whether or not a
feature is enabled for a certain
individual user a customer or for
everyone and thus breaking up your code
release it your code pushes from your
releases makes things so much simpler
and how do our code releases work is
kind of how code pushes work is
basically I make a change it gets pushed
up to Gerrit people we run our tests
automatically run on it say you thumbs
up or thumbs down colleagues do code
reviews thumbs up or thumbs down it's
usually a few thumbs down until thumbs
up and that point we check it in next
day gets deployed to our staging system
which is basically an exact copy of
production with some minor configuration
changes like different crypto keys and
that kind of
and then we do manual testing there and
then the next day it's pushed to what we
call our canary set of customers that's
the picture and those are basically the
customers were randomly selected that
get to try out new things and if there's
any problems there we stop and roll back
we do the same thing for our monthly
feature releases is that some features
are obviously in development for many
months and so we actually have a longer
rollout process for those is our dog
food feature we first rollout to our dog
food tenants which is basically our use
of hire maybe our sales demos and a
couple other things next if it's a big
feature we might roll out to what we
call our trusted tester customers which
is a set of customers that greed to have
beta features and they'll get feedback
and may stay there for months and then
after that it kind of follows the same
process our code pushes it goes to the
canary and then usually the next day -
all all customers and all these all
these different like that we have this
production and I mentioned staging we
also have performance environments where
a set of environments that we have
simulated really large customers and are
running performance tests all of these
different configurations are all almost
the same but different and this is one
place where a cloud platform really
helps us we have all of this all of our
config is checked into the code system
and I'll talk about more about that
later let's basically our release
process so what did we use in cloud
platform to build our wildly successful
application and what did they help and I
mean there's lots of things we've used
I'm just going to cover the big ones
here all right this is kind of a tired
analogy it's the kettled versus pets and
I think people like me include it here
just to give a break and we can all
admire the cute animals but what this
means if you're not familiar with this
is in the bad old days we used to treat
servers like pets is that you'd give
them a name you'd hug them and care for
them and if one of them got sick you
would take it to the vet and make it
make it better nowadays is yet don't do
that
treat your services if they're cattle
they're interchangeable and how do you
do this this is where like kubernetes
engine we're basically all on kubernetes
at this point and what's nice about that
is you kind of all of your configuration
basically checked in and if it's checked
in you can do code reviews on the
configuration and then run tests and we
do that
and talk about this later more but like
configuration changes are really
dangerous as far as running a service
and another nice thing if you're not
familiar with committees is the
configuration isn't like a set of steps
things to deploy it's a description of
what your environment should look like
and you can start doing things like
self-healing on this diffing it when you
make a change all sorts of really nice
things
it took us kind of quite a while to get
there I think our first version here was
just a set of shell scripts we were
making like cloudy API calls and then we
said ok let's use deployment manager
configs we had those checked in at that
point and we were using Google Google
container engine for that compute engine
for that sorry and this all was all
worked fine we were kind of unhappy with
this is with the resource utilization
was bad things like rolling updates
we're having trouble getting the be fat
as fast as we wanted to and our
configuration was starting to get messy
and so we wrote like a templating tool
for that in I says Python this time and
helped a little bit but we were still
making mistakes that we didn't think we
should and so about that time the
kubernetes came out and was production
so we switched over that this was great
we got all the benefits as our rolling
updates were fast our system was more
stable config files we're still kind of
we had checked in Yama files and they
were still kind of big and so we were
having problems where people would
update a staging environment and then
forget to update the production that was
error-prone we wrote actually a
templating tool there we used to go I
guess because you have to use all the
languages but that was so that's kind of
is still a problem and so this year we
switch to something called JSON it this
is another open-source project inspired
by features of the Google internal cloud
we haven't been using this for long
enough but so far it's so happy our
configuration files are smaller still
checked in and we're using basically
this for all of our kubernetes config we
have a little bit of deployment manager
still as far as like what in kubernetes
do we use we have a pretty
straightforward setup here it's we have
I think one cluster a couple note pools
a handful of services so not terribly
interesting we are using like we love
the
rolling updates we get four new changes
talking to people where we're actually
not really using auto-scaling very much
that's probably because we're at Google
and we never actually get the bills I
know that's on our list of things to fix
but I was a little surprised to figure
that out yes I said we're mostly on
kubernetes we have a couple of cloud
functions we're using they're super easy
to spin up I'm a little like anxious of
these bees maybe one of the first ones I
used is I didn't read the documentation
see that theme and there's like a 10
megabyte serving limit and so our
customers grew and we we were like
merging XML files for a job feed and
that went past ten megabytes and we
outage so I'm still a little scared of
them and maybe that's just we're not
using them enough but just something to
think they're alright storage said cloud
spanner is basically using this for all
of our relational data and I'm kind of a
little bit fuzzy here is we actually
predate use of cloud spanner so we have
something that's almost like cloud
spanner but not but we love it we have
like no downtime for our schema changes
really no downtime for anything some
lessons learned here I guess I stopped
talking about schema changes is there
still a pain as far as like writer it's
still our biggest pain point we haven't
found a magic solution for that other
kind of thing is if you look at the
different mode you can setup spanner in
this like I would say go to
multi-regional first if you're thinking
is that we had to re architect things
and our app a little bit when we wanted
to go multi-regional multi-regional
actually slows down your commits and for
various reasons we have in the app what
we call it green dots everywhere that
show whether or not you've read
something like a new comment and what
that meant is that as you're navigating
around our app things that should be
read-only views actually become rights
to the rights to spanner and we were
doing those in line and so when we want
to do a multi-regional they were slow
the transactions for those became slow
enough we had to do a little bit
architecting and your app writers get
unhappy when your database people make
everything slower for you so I would say
fight that off first what else cloud
storage
we're using that lots of places I
mentioned testing already an app we use
this fall like the resumes people upload
companies logos
cover letters we actually use it for all
of the static assets that go to part of
our webpage like the CSS files the HTML
files we love it no real problems here
maybe one one like lessons learned here
is I was looking at like the load time
of our app versus like the load time of
the main Google page why are my CSS
files taking so much longer than
google.com CSS files and turns out I
hadn't enabled I'd enabled
multi-regional cloud storage but had not
turned on a cloud CDN in front of it and
so the multi-regional if you read it it
kind of seems like that's what all you
need but if you're actually serving up
assets you also need to enable cloud CDN
as well that's easy it's easy change
though Oh
memory store is this is at least the
time I wrote this presentation it was in
beta I think lots of things are being
announced so I'm not sure if that's
changed today or not we're really
interested in moving some of our
internal caching over this a lessons
learned here is that we're definitely
not switching over to it until it's out
of beta
there's a reason services are on beta so
believe that Network notice the nice
slide I lake and I were actually trying
to talk and figure out what what should
we put on the slide and his boat was oh
the nice thing about this is or the
praise here is we don't actually have to
talk about this at all it just works so
we have a kind of relatively simple
networking we're using the Google cloud
load balancers SSL termination we're
actually still single region right now
so that makes things a bit simpler we've
prototyped what we need to do from
multi-regional and it doesn't really
change anything so network we're really
happy I have to complain about anything
I would complain a tiny bit about cloud
CDN and as I wished it had a better
invalidation API is that you can
invalidate things in it but you can't
actually make it part of your normal
workflow and there were a couple places
where I wanted to have very long time
outs on some of our static pages and
just rely on invalidation when they
changed and can't do that at least not
yet another quote from my co-workers he
talks about magic tools and the one he
always brings up is is Blanc about how
for certain things it just makes life so
much easier so I thought I'd talk a
little about like what are these magic
tools the things we just love
so first off bigquery I love bigquery
we've talked about how use it for tests
we actually throw all of our performance
stats into bigquery and what we do like
an example of this is if you're in the
browser there's this window dot
performance API is you can use to get
things about like page load times and
how long it took you to download each of
the individual assets and a page it's
all available in the browser and we
actually send those over the server
shove them into bigquery and this is
really useful so example where we use
this was this was a while back and it
was I think after hours and our users
mostly use our app 9:00 to 5:00 and so
you can see like anomalies easier at
those times and we saw this big spike in
page loads where they went you know
usually it's you know a small number of
seconds or less and they went up to like
close to minutes or and that's crazy so
we dug into that and turns out we looked
at our stats and yes we were actually
getting there was one user had a handful
I think a hundred plus page loads that
were taking over a minute and when they
should normally you know take under
under a couple seconds and then we did
the join against our back-end data which
we also have dumped into bigquery and
back-end everything was fast
we started looking all the network
downloads for the individual assets all
those were fast and at this point we
started like scrambling we say Oh what
like we realized oh there's a new
version of Chrome that just came out it
must be that turns out it kind of was is
that chrome had update or slightly
modified how they throttle throttle tabs
in the background it turns out this user
ID opened one of our list views and on
every single entry in there had clicked
open a new tab and all those tabs open
ran long enough for us to get like the
start of the page load measurement and
then got suspended and then when the
user finally ended up clicking on one
they'd finish the page load and since
either since the user had opened up you
know hundreds of these by the time it
got to the end of and of then many of
those had been sitting there for quite a
while and so this was again ok it's easy
we can get the time back rounded and in
our stats push that through and avoid
these and we just ignore these in the
future a bigger thing here though it was
actually like why is this user doing
this and it turns out well we should
have book actions and this was from this
we know ok let's implement a book action
for that yeah so we love bigquery other
things in here
for like lessons learned is we're
initially using a stack driver logging
sink to get the stats from from our log
files into bigquery and on our
performance test setups that turned out
to be we were actually losing a fair
number of logs that way there's actually
a fairly high performance cost we
actually switched and started calling
the bigquery API is directly and since
then we've had no problem so I think
would be query if you haven't used it it
integrates really nicely with data
studio it makes it really easy to spin
up like dashboards or so we had that
happening all the time was like
fellowship some performance improvement
they'll quickly spin up a data studio
dashboard that shows look that you know
things went like that or more normally I
did this improvement and nothing changed
but yeah data studio it's something to
keep an eye on as queries can get
expensive we're part of Google and I
tried to figure out how much it was
costing and I don't couldn't actually
figure out how much bigquery was costing
us so if but yes it something to keep an
eye on but what else trace there's
number this is also just very cool it
basically shows you how long how long it
requests silicon kind of each hop in the
requests as it goes through multiple app
servers or backends how long it took you
do have to integrate it with it a little
bit but for a certain class of problems
it was just the tool that worked see
Club pub/sub another thing we just love
we're like a client of this for some of
the public Gmail API is where we get a
message kind of for each new email
coming in we also use this internally
for sending data to our indexers for
like full-text search basically and the
failure modes for this are great it's
easy to use yeah it was something we
want we should use more yeah so if
you're if you've used our app well we
look like a first party app from Google
is you kind of indistinguishable from
the other Google Apps
we're actually built using basically all
of the public API is that third any
third parties can use and so which ones
do what do we use so I talked a bit
about bigquery talked about cloud
pub/sub cloud storage we use the key
management service this basically lets
us get crypto keys out of our source
code I mentioned you should be checking
all of your configuration and into your
source repository if you do that what do
you do about your crypto keys you don't
want them there
you can go like search on github and
find all these people have published
their crypto keys for the entire world
to see you don't want that to happen to
you
so key management service lets you avoid
that the other big one we use here is
cloud talent solutions that was I
believe we have a talk here on Thursday
I think it's ml AI 108 should definitely
go see go to that talk but what this is
we use this for all of our in-app
candidate searching and we went through
a bunch of iterations here from just
doing kind of straight-up
spanner queries for search in our app
then we switch to using solar for free
text search and we actually switched to
another kind of internal Google thing
for free text search and then at that
point realized actually searches in our
problem is it's not like just matching
if you're trying to search for like
candidates job skills those kind of
things is that you need something
smarter and that's what this is the
example they were bring is if you look
if you're searching for like an
executive or an executive assistant
those are very different and you don't
really want sources for one to show the
other but if you're doing naive free
text search they do and so as cloud
talent solutions solves all those
problems for you across all industries
and it does things like I think it's
even smart enough to know that if you
type in like mmm like military job
titles it knows how to map those to
civilian job titles and I think its job
titles locations skills number other
things so definitely check that out
check out that talk how do we actually
integrate with this our app just inline
makes direct API calls out to cloud
talent solutions we're actually using
cloud pub/sub to send whenever we get
like a new a new candidate new resident
resume uploaded in our app we've pushed
it into a cloud pub/sub have separate
workers that pop it out and then make
the API calls to add those to cloud town
solutions another place we're using pops
up really like it let's see what else we
use sheets quote from like the tech lead
of the sheets team talking a little
while ago was that sheets is the second
best tool in the enterprise for doing
anything and our users users they really
love sheets and so we've been focusing
on doing basically full data exports to
sheets as well as for some of our in-app
reports basically a cooked cooked
version of that report data to sheets
and this lets their users modify the
report build their own reports and do
some modification so we got lots of
requests for
they we like this report but I need to
actually change a little bit as though
that person wasn't actually hired by me
it was hired by this other person even
though in the sisters excuses they want
to bill edit the reports before they
actually show them to other people and
we didn't want to build that in so we
put that into in the sheets drive we use
that for basically any place you upload
it upload a file in our app Gmail we're
doing two things that we actually have a
gmail add-on which basically lets you
see hiring data about it we're directly
in Gmail so you can have seamlessly if
you're corresponding with a candidate
the email you can see what what we know
about it and hire there anyone can write
one of those we're also using the Gmail
API is to basically ingest email
conversations between people on the
hiring team the candidate so you can
view it in our app some lessons learned
on Gmail Gmail has a billion users lots
of servers and it's totally willing to
do a denial service attack against you
if you're not ready for it
also just some of the data shape can be
weird is that we kind of expect it oh
we'll have a you know a any given
candidate will have a few hundred
messages associated with them between
the hiring team and you can get it to
the point where especially some people
of hundreds of thousands and if you're
not ready for that that can be a problem
calendar it's done a lot with calendar
there it's we've actually built we call
it multi slot scheduler if you look at
the interview day it's one person
meeting a bunch of people in a bunch of
rooms and so we've built this multi slot
scheduler it's actually bi-directional
sync so you can in calendar you couldn't
like adjust an interview schedule and it
will reflect in our app and vice versa
and all this is built with the public
API and here's a quote from one of the
engineers on this is don't do it
calendars are really hard all sorts of
crazy corner cases that's true but it's
by far our most loved feature so
definitely do it just realize what
you're signing up for api's are powerful
and calendars is you know if you might
think they're simple they're not we have
to deal with non Google calendars time
zones weird configuration settings
permissions spam filters I know so we've
we thought it was getting or more if
you're doing stuff with color and just
realize that the API is are really
powerful and what you're going to get is
going to look so seamless that your
customers are going to want you to
provide support for calendar
and we're part of Google and we actually
have trouble is that with the internal
you know access guidelines there's no
way I can help one of our customers
debug a calendar problem that's some
other team and if you're outside of
Google that's going to be a problem as
well and one last lesson learned here is
that once you start internet calendar
your tests have time in them and once
you have time in your test your tests
are gonna fail on like New Year's Day
New Year's Eve leap years leap days
daylight savings time I've lived with it
it's kind of annoying um it's a lessons
learned
yeah in the past several years I've
learned way more lessons than I can keep
track of here's a top couple and some of
them are can seem really obvious but
since they're things I had to learn I
might as well talk about them so this is
automate everything people screw up and
at least if your software makes a
mistake you can write a test fix the bug
file the bug fix it it won't happen
again
can't really do that with users and so
I'm claiming that we built a wildly
successful application with happy users
and ways we've actually screwed up is
we've deployed ancient builds to
production as in like months old we
deploy builds we hadn't qualified yet to
production I would say we've done most
of these before we did that and that my
journey of those four slides is most of
those were prior to our end point we are
now I've actually destroyed our entire
staging system more times than I can man
this is the case with luckily is all of
our servers are stateless all the
configuration checked in it's really
easy just to deploy it again we've
actually destroyed all of our production
app servers we almost use this as a
troubleshooting problem the times no
something weirds going on just kill all
the app servers make the whole turn it
off and turn it on again thing it still
works we've actually just I think this
was before we had paying customers we
actually did destroy all of our
production system once and had to
restore from backup the other thing here
is that Google we've practiced we
complain less blameless post mortem
culture and this is where when like
someone screws up is you don't say hey
you're fired get out of here you say ok
you need to write up a post mortem about
what went wrong talking about what went
wrong like where you got lucky were you
done lucky
and enlist a set of action items to
prevent this from ever happening again
and usually those are automate another
quote from my colleague Bo test that
your backups work everyone knows this
only 10% of teams do this and yeah
everyone knows this I would say test
that your restores work who cares if the
backups are going okay
I did say was we have actually had to
restore from backup and it might have
been me I'm sorry but luckily you can
always keep your existing existing
database around and figure out what what
happened during that interval and replay
it before customers show up the next
morning yeah definitely test your
backups let's see it's a lame duck mode
that's kind of awesome doc but what this
is is it talks about when you're doing
either a rolling update or scaling up
scaling down is how you deal with
requests to your existing app servers or
the app servers that are being torn down
and there's other things those oh yes we
should do this we'll get around to it
it's one of those things by it's not a
big deal and so we ignored it for a
really long time and then what happened
is somewhat embarrassing is our sales
team came to us as saying we're running
these demos and every once in a while
things slow down and get really slow and
we get awkward because they run out of
things to talk about and if your sales
team is saying that they're running out
of things to talk about that's that's
definitely a problem so what we did was
we had actually been tracking like we
know what our p99 page loads and all
those looked good and and so when we dug
some more and said ok actually no the
salespeople aren't lying to us things
are actually slow sometimes and a big
portion of this was actually from how we
were dealing with these rolling updates
and example of what would happen is if
we were either a new app server comes
alive either from a rolling update or
auto scaling as we'd start we were
actually sending a request to it before
it was ready to handle those and then
either they would fail and get bounced
another app server or worse they would
hang out there and wait for the database
initialization or other stuff to finish
and you get a slow request again this is
kind of super obvious things and there's
great support for this we just weren't
doing it similar one was as we were
tearing down app servers you get the
cases somewhat longer request would come
in one app server get partway done app
sorry that killed it gets into the next
one since we were rolling updates it
could someday
balance between multiple app servers and
so the party yeah yeah kind of kind of
embarrassing and so the things here
again it's all in the documentation do
it using kubernetes you have a readiness
check make sure your readiness check is
actually correct I think our first
version of that we were reporting
readiness when we were thought we were
ready not when we were actually ready
there's liveness checks you need you can
implement and what else do I have here
oh I guess also if you're looking
kubernetes make sure you have a sig term
Handler and then also look at your
configure connection draining time out
so it's also matter here so this was and
this is something we actually went
another place where cloud trace really
helped us it's looking at these
individually really slow requests all
right last but not least is have an
awesome design and product team I
probably should have said this first it
doesn't matter how like technically
awesome your application is if ordinary
humans either can't figure out how to
use it or don't want to use it this is
something that cloud platform is not
going to help you with right now at
least until the ml and AI teams get
their act together so you really need
really good product and design people
and I know this personally is our first
couple versions of hire we actually
didn't really have a design team at the
time and they were pretty pretty
embarrassing a bad they were designed by
people like me and nothing worse than
realizing that the software you designed
is awful so don't let that happen to
your team love your designers and they
totally didn't pay me to put this slide
up here all right
that's basically it if your team is
hiring you need help with the process go
hired at google.com to check us out if
you're looking for a job we were looking
for back in front end designers product
people come talk to me afterwards
[Music]